leben ist selbst unter extremsten
umweltbedingungen hier auf der erde
möglich zb in den heißen thermalquellen
auf dem boden der tiefsee ein indiz
dafür dass es auch auf unwirtlichen
planeten oder monde außerirdisches leben
geben könnte
jetzt hat ein forschungsteam entdeckt
das wohl selbst in riesen höhlen der
antarktis ganze bislang unbekannte
ökosysteme existieren könnten auf welche
lebensformen die gefundenen dna-spuren
hinweisen und warum diese entdeckung
auch außerirdisches leben wieder ein
stück weiter wahrscheinlich macht jetzt
den blick zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
in bodenproben aus den warmen höhlen
unter antarktischen gletschern hatten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
schon vor einiger zeit die dna spuren
von bakterien und pilzen identifizieren
können ein australisches forschungsteam
hat nun darin überraschender weise auch
dna spuren von verschiedenen arten von
moos gliederfüßler fadenwürmern und
algen entdeckt ein hinweis darauf dass
dort pflanzen tiere ja sogar ganze
ökosysteme existieren könnten bisher
unbekannte lebensform quasi aliens auf
der erde der tatort der mount erebus auf
ross island und drei weitere vulkane in
dieser region unter ihnen existiert ein
verzweigtes system von tunneln die
einmal durch die heißen dämpfe der
vulkane entstanden sind die grundlage
für leben an diesen orten seit
tatsächlich gegeben so das
forschungsteam nahe manchen höhlen
eingängen gibt es wo licht und in den
höhlen selbst kann es bis zu 25 grad
warm werden eine beteiligte forscherin
erzählt beispielsweise dass man in den
höhlen selbst tatsächlich ein t shirt
tragen kann
diese bedingungen sicherten die
energieversorgung von leben so die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
neben dieser entdeckung sind vor allem
diejenigen gen fragmente in den proben
spannend die sich einfach nicht
identifizieren lassen
dies spricht nämlich für bislang
unbekannte tier und pflanzenarten die in
den antarktischen riesen höhen leben
oder aber lebten denn das ist auch klar
die dna spuren sind nicht unbedingt ein
beweis dafür dass die lebewesen auch
noch heutzutage in den höhlen existieren
doch weitere expeditionen sind in
planung
und tatsächlich auch durchaus
realistisch denn nur wenige kilometer
entfernt vom mount erebus liegt die
größte logistikbasis auf dem
antarktischen kontinent die mac modus
station mit mehr als 1100 einwohnern
zumindest im sommer zudem vermuten die
forschungsteams das auch unter den etwa
15 anderen vulkan in der antarktis
höhlensysteme unter dem eis zu finden
sein müssten doch die gilt es noch zu
finden und zu erforschen jedenfalls
macht die entdeckung des australischen
forschungsteams wieder einmal auf ein
neues deutlich wie wenig wir selbst von
unserem heimatplaneten wissen auf dem
wir leben wie viele orte es noch zu
entdecken und zu erforschen gibt sehr
wahrscheinlich
dass wir noch immer viel zu viele orte
auf der erde beziehungsweise im ganzen
universum für lebensversicherten obwohl
sie leben tatsächlich zu lassen wohl
genauso wie die unendlichen weiten des
äußeren sonnensystems wir haben ja schon
öfter darüber berichtet forschungsteams
weltweit wissen mittlerweile dass die
theorie der habitablen zone überaltert
ist und das biologische aktivität wie zb
auf den sogenannten supererden durchaus
möglich ja sogar wahrscheinlich ist denn
selbst hier unter den extremsten
bedingungen überhaupt auf der erde sind
die zutaten für leben vorhanden genauso
wie auf dem saturnmond enceladus der im
inneren eben nicht zugefroren ist wie
die raumsonde cassini gezeigt habe wie
eigentlich vorher vermutet wurde
und so belegt die aktuelle entdeckung
der australier auf ein neues dass die
bausteine des lebens fast überall
zusammen können kommen können und die
indizien für außerirdisches leben werden
immer mehr hier bei pixum halte ich euch
speziell zum thema außerirdisches leben
immer auf dem laufenden wenn er kein
video zum thema und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
drücken wir ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den auf die glocke hier
geht es weiter mit außerirdisches leben
auf der erde
da geht es um spektakuläre funde in
mexikanischen höhlen also nicht
verpassen und draufklicken ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran